>> Laura: THE GREAT
NANCY PELOSI CRACK-UP, THE FOCUS
OF THE ANKLE.
NANCY PELOSI DOESN'T SEEM WELL,
THE NANCY PELOSI I REMEMBER IT
WAS A HARD-CHARGING CONGRESSMAN
WENT WITH BIG, BOLD IDEAS.
ALTHOUGH REPUBLICANS OPPOSED HER
OBAMA TAX AND SPEND, THE
STIMULUS OR HURT OBAMACARE
CRAMDOWN, AT LEAST SHE WAS DOING
SOMETHING.
NOW SHE SPENDS HER DAYS OBSESSED
WITH PRESIDENT TRUMP, MUTTERING
AND SPUTTERING.
>> OF THESE COULD BE IMPEACHABLE
OFFENSES, BUT I INTEND --
THE THREE THINGS.
YOU MIGHT UNDERSTAND IT IF YOU
REMEMBER THESE THREE THINGS.
>> Laura: NO.
HERE ARE MY THREE THANKS NANCY.
NUMBER ONE, WHEN YOU CANNOT
PRODUCE A COHERENT THOUGHT MAYBE
IT'S TIME TO HANG IT UP.
NUMBER TWO, YOU'VE HAD A GALA
FOR FOUR MONTHS AND YOU HAVE
NOTHING TO SHOW FOR IT BUT
RESISTANCE.
NUMBER, YOU AS LEADER OF THE
DEMOCRATS ARE DOING A GRAVE
DISSERVICE, REAL DAMAGE TO
AMERICA BY REPEATEDLY REFUSING
TO RECOGNIZE THE LEGITIMACY OF
THE DULY ELECTED PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES AND HAS APPOINTED
CABINET.
THINK ABOUT THIS.
BOTH JOE BIDEN THE 2020 FRONT
RUNNER AND SPEAKER PELOSI ARE
NOT JUST OUT OF STEP FOR THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE ON KEY ISSUES,
TO WATCH AND TO OBSERVE THEM, WE
SEE THAT THEY HAVE LOST A STEP
OR TWO OR THREE PERIOD.
THEY LOOK LIKE THEY BELONG IN
COMMERCIALS FOR VISITING ANGELS,
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE THEIR HANDS
ON ANY LEVERS OF POWER.
STAY AWAY.
YESTERDAY SHE SEEMED TO STRUGGLE
WITH THE WHOLE SUBJECT, VERB,
DIRECT OBJECT THING.
>> AS YOU CAN SEE, THE
DISTINGUISHED LEADER ON THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE, WE
SENATOR  --
>> Laura: JOE BIDEN?
THAT SITUATION IS GETTING WORSE
BY THE DAY.
THE COUNTRY WASN'T BUILT BY
WALL STREET BANKERS, CEOs AND
HEDGE FUND MANAGERS.
THE SAME IS HAPPENING AND BIG
HOSPITALS.
I THINK WE HAVE TO RETHINK HOW
WE DEFINE WHAT CONSTITUTES A
SUCCESSFUL ECONOMY.
>> Laura: [LAUGHS]
CAN YOU IMAGINE?
GOING UP AGAINST PRESIDENT OF
CHINA?
WHO WOULD HELP US?
NANCY PELOSI IS NOW THE LEADER
OF THE DO-NOTHING PARTY.
COME ON.
THIS IS BEYOND ALL VS.
THINK OF ONE ISSUE LIKE ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION ON THE BORDER
CRISIS, DEMOCRATS ALONE ARE TO
BLAME FOR THE SHAMELESS
OVERCAPACITY SITUATION AT HER
STATION, WE JUST TALKED ABOUT
THAT WITH THE SECRETARY.
THE HORRENDOUS EFFECTS OF THE
CRISIS AND WHAT IT HAS ON THE
HEALTH AND WELFARE OF AMERICANS
AND ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
NO ONE SHOULD LEAVE TOWN
MEMORIAL DAY PARADES OR
FUND-RAISERS OVER OCCASIONS
UNTIL THE NECESSARY FIXES ARE
PUT IN PLACE FOR OUR BORDER.
INSTEAD, THIS IS HER FOCUS.
>> I DO THINK OF THAT
IMPEACHMENT IS A VERY DIVISIVE
PLACE TO GO IN OUR COUNTRY.
IF WE CAN GET THE FACTS TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, IT MAY TAKE US
TO A PLACE THAT IS UNAVOIDABLE.
WE ARE NOT AT THAT PLACE.
>> Laura: INVESTIGATION?
WHAT A FRAUD.
APPARENTLY IT WASN'T ENOUGH TO
WASTE $35 MILLION WITH TAXPAYER
DOLLARS AND TWO YEARS OF TIME,
DEMOCRATS FEEL LIKE THE OLD TO A
MORE IN-DEPTH INVESTIGATION THAT
A SPECIAL COUNSEL WITH HOW MANY
19 LAWYERS INCLUDING MANY
DEMOCRATS?
THEY WILL THE REAL INVESTIGATION
ON CAPITOL HILL.
THEY COULDN'T INVESTIGATE THEIR
WAY OUT OF A PAPER BAG.
THIS IS ALL POLITICS.
NANCY PELOSI WILL CONTINUE TO DO
WHAT YOU JUST DID AND THAT SOUND
BITE.
TO DANGLE AT THE PROSPECT OF
IMPEACHMENT TO MOLLIFY HER NASTY
BASE OF RADICALS AND COURSE TO
IRK THE PRESIDENT.
THIS IS THE MOST SERIOUS CONCERN
OF ALL, SHE IS CHIPPING AWAY AT
THE FOUNDATION OF OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL REPUBLIC.
WHEN ONE SIDE LOSES THE OTHER
SIDE ACCEPTS THE OUTCOME OF THE
ELECTION.
I REMEMBERED WHEN THEY ARE
WONDERING IF TRUMP WAS GOING TO
ACCEPT THE OUTCOME IF HILLARY
WON, THAT SHE WAS ON THE OTHER
FOOT.
DEMOCRATS HAVE NEVER SEEN TRUMP
AS A LEGITIMATE PRESIDENT.
THE QUEEN OF SAN FRANCISCO HAS
PICKED UP WHERE THE DEEP STATE
LEFT OFF.
>> I PRAY FOR THE PRESIDENT OF
UNITED STATES.
I WISH HIS FAMILY OR HIS STAFF
WOULD HAVE AN INTERVENTION FOR
THE GOOD OF THE COUNTRY.
MAYBE HE WANTS TO TAKE A LEAVE
OF ABSENCE, I DON'T KNOW.
>> Laura: MAY BE YOU DO TO
TAKE A LEAVE OF ABSENCE.
IS SHE ACTUALLY QUESTIONING HIS
PHYSICAL OR MENTAL CONDITION
WHEN WE HAVE BASIC VERB
CONJUGATION PROBLEMS UP THERE ON
CAPITOL HILL?
IF ANYONE NEEDS TO HAVE A
TIMEOUT, IT'S NANCY PELOSI WHO
HAS A VENT IN THE JFK TO THE
PARTY OF AOC.
THE PRESIDENT APPARENTLY IS
SEEING WHAT I AM SEEING.
>> I'VE BEEN WATCHING HER AND I